dernière étape dans ce centre
d'esthétique à voisins le bretonneux
épilation minceur et anti âge cet
institut est dirigée par nathalie puig
elle a dû cesser son activité du fait du
second confinement mais a néanmoins
maintenu la vente de produits à distance
c'est parti on va l'avoir
[Musique]
nathalie pic bonjour bonjour
dirigeante de ce centre d'esthétique zen
institut alors comment ça se passe pour
vous eh bien ça se passe que je suis
fermé depuis vendredi matin 30 octobre
une que je ne pratique plus aucune
prestation auprès de ma clientèle et du
coup quelles conséquences ça peut avoir
conséquence directe des ce2 chiffre
d'affaires au moins 70 % puisque c'est
ce que représente mes prestations
et face à cette situation comment vous
est adapté alors je me suis adapté la
vitesse de l'éclair puisque le week-end
dernier j'ai créé une boutique en ligne
que j'ai mis en service dès lundi matin
pour que les clients puissent acheter en
click and collect elle commande sur mon
site internet
elle paye et j'organise des rendez-vous
pour qu'elles viennent chercher à la
porte de l'institut leurs produits vous
avez beaucoup d'attentes ça va être une
réussite
cette nouvelle stratégie entre minuit
alors j'ai beaucoup d'attentes parce que
finalement il faut toujours tirer le
meilleur des plus mauvaises situations
si ça fonctionne j'espère faire perdurer
cette cette fonctionnalité de vente avec
une collecte en plus de la vente en
magasin lorsque je serai réouverte
merci nathalie clic avec plaisir
dirigeante de zen institut
[Musique]